[Music]
climate change has been named to be the
most serious Public Health Challenge of
the 21st century and that's for
Myriad reasons the most obvious one is
heat and heat itself it's estimated
every year causes several hundred
thousand deaths around the world but
it's not just heat we have the other
extreme weather events that are becoming
more common and intense with climate
change and all of those have serious
health consequences one aspect that's
underappreciated now is that all of
these extreme events cause population
displacement people lose their homes and
that causes long-term medical issues in
addition there are issues with
infectious diseases because the world is
getting warmer mosquitoes and ticks tend
to live better in a warming world so
we're seeing an expansion of what we
call vector-borne diseases we're also
very concerned about the adverse health
effects of human activities that cause
climate change most notably the burning
of fossil fuels it emits toxic air
pollutants
the vision of the Yale Center on climate
change and health
is a safe and stable climate
in which human health and diverse
ecosystems can Thrive and also very
importantly we integrate social justice
into all of our work
[Music]
when people first think of climate
change the image people think of is
polar bear but polar bear is too distant
what we try to argue here is climate
change is essentially a public health
issue it is about the hot House of your
parents about the mental health of your
case about the kidney House of you so
this is really about you your friends
your your neighbors your family in order
to achieve the admission
we need to reveal the full spectrum of
the content impacts on health because if
people don't know about it then of
course people can just ignore it when we
started climate change and health it's
essentially because the climate problem
is
a multi-disciplinary problem it's a
problem that the whole society faces
thus it requires a whole societal
approaches ranging from climate sense
air pollution science environmental
epidemiology machine learning approaches
Cardiology all the different approaches
together to understand really how
climate change could impact our health
the ultimate goal of the trend lab is to
produce policy relevant scientific
evidence our recent research focused on
the ambient carbon monoxide impacts on
mortality in multiple countries around
the world that research supports
Waterhouse organizations ambient air
quality guidelines for carbon monoxide
for the first time
[Music]
the online certificate program is one of
the first if not the first of its kind
in the country if not the world geared
towards working professionals and the
real goal of this program is to bring
folks from around the disciplines and
professions needed to make strides on
climate change and health
so we have a concentration in climate
change and health for MPH students the
great thing about how this is designed
is that because it's a concentration it
brings students from around the entire
school and so all of the Departments of
the school to learn about climate change
and health and how they can apply the
skills and the knowledge from their
particular programs
[Music]
our policy and practice
pillar is critical to assuring that our
work has impact we need to take our
research and our education and Link it
with what's happening on the ground
particularly for an issue like climate
change and health where there are
important policy decisions happening
today there's important interventions
that need to happen to protect People's
Health the center on climate change and
health worked closely with the
Department of Public Health in
Connecticut to apply for and receive a
CDC climate Health Grant there are only
a few of these grants given around the
country so it's a big deal for
Connecticut to have one for the first
time through the grant they establish an
office of climate and public health this
office will work with local Health
departments with communities with other
stakeholders to develop strategies to
protect People's Health especially
around heat and air quality here in
Connecticut we've traditionally thought
about climate change as something that
happens far away somewhere else in the
future to to non-humans but that's not
true we know that it's happening right
now here in our communities and that
it's affecting our health what's
powerful about that is that it means
that we can engage people on it in a way
that feels really upfront in their lives
and so a lot of our work is working with
communities talking about these issues
finding solutions that are addressing
their their current priorities
addressing their health and how it's
affected by climate change and and also
addressing the kinds of drivers of
climate change in their homes in their
in their transportation systems that
those Solutions have a health benefit
too